what do you think of the the new rule to
require vaccination
for nhs staff
i'm not happy about that so you're not
happy with it
so i've had cove at some point yes i've
got antibodies yeah um i've been working
on covered it since the beginning i have
not had a vaccination
i did not want to have a vaccination
it looks as though we might not have to
dr steve james is with us now hi dr
james thank you for joining us on the
program why did you feel it necessary to
to challenge the health secretary in
that way
uh there's an opportunity i think
hundreds of thousands of people would
have liked to have taken um it was
simply there in front of me and i chose
to speak my mind
uh why do you not want to have a job
i never felt i would need to be
vaccinated i always thought that healthy
people wouldn't even be offered the
vaccine it was going to go for
vulnerable people
i've never seen someone who's written
well
on intensive care
i know i know some people have had
serious problems from cobit who've been
otherwise well um and i assumed that it
would be offered to
adults and but never sort of given a
message that everybody should take it
and certainly not for healthy children
is it not the social responsibility of
healthy people to look after those who
aren't
i believe it's the social responsibility
of healthy people to get natural
immunity i think it's much uh
historically much more likely to be long
lasting than a vaccine-induced immunity
and i think studies are bearing that out
now
but if they've contracted covert they
could pass it on in that period of time
that they potentially wouldn't have to
the same extent if they had had a
vaccination is the suggestion from the
nhs
well listen suggestion and there's some
data showing that with delta there was
some reduction for a few months
in the ability to transmit it but you've
got to remember one very key thing
asymptomatic transmission is a
idea that came from computer model
generation it's not real world data so
if you're sick and you stay away from
other people you won't transmit it
what about if you don't know if you've
got it
well if you haven't got any symptoms
you're not transmitting it
okay so you can't transmit covert even
though you don't have any symptoms
because again that's not what we've been
told
if if you're pre-centred so no no sorry
let me cut myself there so if you're
about to get symptoms but don't
recognize it that's possible but in that
tiny little window
we haven't got evidence showing that at
least not in a healthcare setting that
makes a difference we know that in
household contacts with delta
recent uh immunization reduces that but
we haven't compared people who were
previously exposed versus those who
weren't exposed to corona who had
vaccines didn't have vaccines and we
certainly never tested it in a hospital
setting
but as you point out there doctors quite
often you don't know you've got it until
you've done the test
no i didn't say that
i said that most of the time um
when you have got symptoms that's when
you're transmitting and when you haven't
got symptoms you're not transmitting and
there's a very small window where you're
pre-symptomatic and go on so if you
don't go on to get symptoms and you
tested positive you're not transmitting
it
no but you could have had i don't know
runny nose whatever the symptoms were
when you had um omicron and certainly uh
when it be when it was the delta variant
you don't know you've got it at that
stage until you've done your lateral
flow and then confirmed by your pcr test
so in that window you can infect other
people including the elderly
yes you can pass it on but we know that
with omicron it's very clear
that that doesn't happen that the
vaccine doesn't protect you from onboard
transmission
we also know that with delta the
transmission was only reduced for a few
months post vaccine and we also know
that that's not comparing people who've
got naturally into versus people who
hadn't gotten that community and got the
vaccination
this is what the nhs say research has
shown the vaccines help reduce your risk
of getting seriously ill or dying from
covid19 reduce your risk of catching or
spreading covered 19 and protect against
covid 19 variants
yes that's correct and that's based on
the delta information and comparing
people who were vaccinated versus
unvaccinated not looking at people
who've already got immunity
so that's not why that's not applicable
enough data to the whole of the nhs
staff and it's not relevant on crime
and you will not be having a covert
vaccination under any circumstances i
will not be having a copied vaccination
and not a nest the entire landscape of
covert and the vaccine changes and you
know vaccine mandates are wrong
um yeah just just to put it to you
finally before i let you go our resident
doc our resident gp said that you are
being selfish
okay
i think a hundred thousand other people
uh in the nhs think that we're speaking
our mind because we do not want to be
coerced into having a vaccine a vaccine
that's still in experimental trial
stages a vaccine that's got side effects
that are not really clearly talked about
at present and people are concerned that
they're higher than a being shared a
vaccine that isn't really very effective
in stopping serious disease in the
healthy population because the healthy
population doesn't get very serious
disease from covered but you acknowledge
that it's saved a lot of life people
being vaccinated as opposed to
where we would be if if we hadn't gone
down that route
absolutely acknowledged that it has
saved lives of the elderly the
vulnerable those who immunocompromised
got severe comorbid disease
in that population and has made a
significant difference together with the
improved care in hospital and the other
treatments have been made available
good to talk to you doctor thank you so
much for taking the time thank you
thank you kay bye bye
bye